fast food restaurants are now entering
the virtual reality races I'm Dave and
welcome to your 100% beef gamespot news
update with oculus rift HTC vive and
PlayStation VR all launching this year
2016 appears poised to be the Year
virtual reality really takes off now
another player is emerged but it may not
be who you expect fast food chain
McDonald's today announced happy goggles
of virtual reality headset made out of a
Happy Meal box really according to
adweek happy goggles will be rolled out
at 40 McDonald's establishments in
Sweden over the weekends of March fifth
and March 12 in all around 3,500 will be
made going for around four bucks each
McDonald's representative tells the site
the Sweden is a test market for advice
if it's popular it's possible the
initiative will expand to other regions
potentially including the United States
like Google cardboard happy goggles
works the smartphone you may already own
there is a basic looking skiing game
shown in the video which was made by
North Kingdom Stockholm so would a dose
of virtual reality make your meal happy
or does this new idea leave you feeling
kind of salty let us know in the comment
section below or you can find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave and roll your
gaming and entertainment news stay tuned
to gamespot com